en train en voiture ou à pied ils sont
des milliers chaque jour à quitter
l'ukraine
medica petite ville à la frontière
polonaise est devenu une route de
transit pour ces réfugiés
de kiev en ukraine et nous allons à
cracovie en pologne
ap rémy schl la grande ville voisine des
bénévoles ont distribué de la nourriture
et des vêtements une étape pour ces
voyageurs avant qu'ils ne poursuivent
leur route
à ce jour la pologne a accueilli le plus
grand nombre de réfugiés ukrainien soit
plus d'un million de personnes elle est
suivie par la hongrie puis la slovaquie
enfin près de 180 mille réfugiés se sont
déplacés plus à l'ouest dans des pays
non frontaliers l'union européenne
connaît désormais une crise humanitaire
à l'intérieur de ses frontières
pour y faire face les dirigeants ont
décidé d'accorder un permis de séjour
temporaires aux ukrainiens c'est le
bombardement continue comme ça sur le
compte lumière bombarder des villes et
façon indiscriminée et on peut
s'attendre
à 5 million de milles en dit long non
pas les appeler milan s'est exilé c'est
des gens qui cherchent échapper la
guerre en plus des réfugiés l'union
européenne estime que près de 7 millions
d'ukrainiens pourrait se retrouver
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays